alright thank you first and foremost
welcome everyone it's very glad to see I
very glad to see so many of you here
today it's a great honor to be here this
is actually my second scariest talk the
scariest one I've ever had is one in
Japan where I was live translated into
Japanese with jokes being 15 seconds
later it's horrible so see how this goes
yeah so this talk is about user
experience rather it's about all the
stuff I've learned during the last three
years of building appearing from what
was essentially a tech demo into what is
like a successful product or semi
successful product at least so hope it's
going to be relevant for you as you can
learn something as well yeah as
mentioned i am logging yeah i am tech
lead in appearing and I've been sort of
around all over the code base both
back-end and front-end and I'm also
doing a lot of the product developments
and some of the marketing work as well
it's been very insightful so I always
have to ask how many of you are familiar
with appearing from before row fans all
right so about twenty percent so that
means I can go through my introduction
slides basically we are a video chat
service based in browsers and a mobile
devices and we're built on something
called web RTC and we provide what is
sort of a different user experience and
a different approach to video chatting
than what you may have seen before there
are a lot of sources are similar to this
but basically what you do is equal to a
pair of in / anything can be your name
or the name of your company or the name
of your team and you send a thank you
everyone to talk to you and once they
click it they will appear with high
quality audio and video we don't need to
register no need to download anything it
just works this is sort of a showcase of
the power of the web just let this work
and we launched back in 2013 as the
first sort of commercial product based
on this so we
then having subtraction and learned a
lot about what it means to actually
build products but it all started with
the interns as many projects do so we
were once like an R&D company inside a
large telecom operator may be doing a
lot of communication apps and every
summer we would have students from
universities that we hired in and we
starting to do projects that were sore a
little bit cool and like you sort of
play around and learn stuff and we were
their mentors and we had this idea we
know that vibrancy was coming we didn't
know a lot about it other than it was
for peer-to-peer video we wanted to see
what we can create with it in addition
we've had a lot of problems with getting
us a nose to work I mean we spent 10
minutes every day trying to just get the
damn thing to work that's very annoying
that is idea that what if it could work
with you just sending a link to someone
and then it just magically worked the
link was sort of the room so this week
so we had three students and we had six
weeks and we have this idea and it was a
very ambitious project but the dynastar
feel free to choose the technology such
as how the service looked and how they
worked after two weeks we have our first
demo so he assumes sort of shaking and
we're very ashamed of the things that
are created they showed up there in
front of like 50 people most of them
engineers and showed us something quite
amazing actually we got our minds blown
because they they showed off not only
having one to one video communication
where pretend made it work for groups
and this was so good that during the
demo people typing in the URL that we
were using and joining the chat as well
and this was at least in 2013 this was
yeah mind-blowing nobody had seen
anything like this before and I worked
in chrome stable and later in firefox
and off-brand other demos as well or
other browsers as well so needs to say
excitement was high and was this sort of
early demo I sort of got us into the
idea this can actually turn into a
product so the last four remaining weeks
we get them a designer and we get
some some more feedback and how he can
actually develop this into a product
that we launched and I was the initial
story of how aperion actually came to
and you can recognize a lot from the
service that you saw before and to serve
the day built after six weeks the video
layouts is mostly the same but the
colors a bit different now and they're
much more functionalities and after the
intern perious was finished we decided
we should just launched and this is sort
of in a telecom industry launchers are
measured in millions both in amount of
money you spend on how many users you
reach but we decided to do something a
bit different and we were luck to do
that because during summer in Norway
there's about this four or five week
period of time where all the grown-ups
are on holiday basically so nobody's
there to tell you I probably shouldn't
do this so you wrote a quick blog post
you posted it on hacker news and read it
because that's how you sort of launch
stuff back in the day or probably not as
well and the feedback we got was just
amazing we got a lot of attention the
same reaction that we got in that first
initial demo and while our service
struggled and there were a lot of things
we should have done better and we
crashed a lot people in general sort of
saw the ID and we saw that this was
something that we should really put more
focus into that gives me to the first
lesson I overheard a conversation
earlier today about some guy I don't
know his name or wasn't meant to listen
to on a conversation or anything but he
wanted to launch its open-source project
no no no I have to it uses require Jess
so I have to do it in something other
the other thing and it's have to redo de
Pisan that kind stuff that doesn't
matter you should just launched early if
you aren't a little bit afraid or a
little bit ashamed of what you're
launching you're watching too late
because the best feedback looking yet is
that actually someone uses your product
they love it and you get motivation from
that and you get prioritization what
should actually fix instead of just
sitting there and sort of coding away
and not really know in the direction
that you want to go in and unending up
never launching and if we haven't
launched back then when this was so
fresh we might have never been where we
are today
because we got a lot of attention from
being the first mover yeah we had a
rocky first few months we were a bit
lucky to have another project shut down
so we had a lot of engineers to sort of
pick and choose from from day one so we
set up a small team we had like three
redesigns we tried to figure out who we
were and what do you want to be until we
finally thought that we had it we were
going to be the world's biggest web RTC
video conferencing service yeah but that
doesn't really work and the middle II we
did get a lot of positive feedback
because we were web RTC based and I was
kind of cool and hip at a time and that
gave us a lot of buzz and initial
attention another blog post i got those
users but in the end the truth was that
the average user couldn't care less
barberton see simply wasn't important to
them robert c wasn't why people loved us
at least not directly because when it
all came down to it all of these
services work I mean skype facetime
hangouts a messenger they all work for
the average user and most of the
conversations that you have are between
people that you're already connected to
your already taking the investment of
downloading this application setting it
up and it just works for you so what
work is he in itself was not something
that would get us users you have to go
back and sort of figure out what could
we build that was better I figure out
what was the reason prefer people
preferred us over those other much
larger services because you could see
that we were getting users we're getting
attention outside the fact that it was
we're about to see based so we started
looking at what people said oh we got
customer support feedback got Twitter
messages or comments on blog posts and
the same sort of tats has now become
more tagline is no logins no installs
and free for update people and just
share the link it was super easy and
everyone could do it so it was really
the user experience of it all that made
the difference
we are creating something that was
easier and better than the alternatives
and have nothing to do with technology
at least not directly and once we change
focus do that a lot of other people also
started talking about us because we
changed our marketing massive change the
message that we were sending with the
product and then marketing sort of
happened for us because people when
people love your product they will
actually share it to their friends and
they will be the market energy that you
need so user experience is what made us
better but technology was the enabler
and think that's important to remember
for a lot of other stuff as well because
the user doesn't care about technology
and this is true for whether you're
building a product where you're building
a library in the end nobody really cares
if you're using reactor angular behind
the scenes nobody cares what build
system we have spending time building
the product and figuring out what the
product is and how it works it's that
much more important than spending time
for example scaling to 200 million users
without you actually having a product
that will do that okay so people loved
us but they weren't coming back that was
a sort of our second issue so we knew
that sort of from the feedback that we
got that we had something that worked
but retention was sort of low this is
pretty common for many other
applications as well after all other
services work just fine and we have this
sort of recurring feedback to us but we
really think your product is the future
but that doesn't really help us we need
users and people now to get funding to
keep going doing this so we have to find
ways to make a product more sticky but
how do you actually do that how do you
find these magical ways that would
actually get people to come back well we
started out small so this is a sign in
Norwegian I'll translate for you it's
the actual song we used around oslo
it's basically said we will buy you
coffee if you spend 15 minutes testing
alternate video chat because we have
this problem where users are global we
had a lot of users everywhere and since
we didn't have user registration it was
hard to get in touch with them but when
it comes down to it most of you users
are ahead of you so by just going out
there and actually start talking to
people and trying to understand what
their problems are how they use
application today and sort of what they
think about your application or whatever
your building is very very important and
doing something small like this which
isn't perfect it's much better than not
doing anything at all that's the next
lesson we sort of learned was actually
talk to you users because the only your
users know what they need what they want
what their problems are and how your
product can fit in to solve those
problems because creating a cool service
is meaningless if it doesn't solve a
user problem take for example Google
Wave which when it was launched in some
of the coolest tech presentation that
I've seen in my life I mean I don't know
how many actually saw that but it's they
showed off live editing the deafening
thing and it was just whatever google
docs house now they that was it but
google wave in itself did not solve any
user problems i still have problems
describing what google wave walls I so
can't sort of described was it a task
manager was there a collaboration thing
I actually don't know but I took the
technologies that out there and put into
other products but actually solved user
needs like in Google Docs
so I want to talk to you about two ways
of getting feedback as well so there's
two ways of doing research I do have
quantitative data or you have
qualitative data and very often I see
that a lot of people use quantitative
data and only that so you have metrics
and have your funnels and you try to
measure all things in your application
and that's fine because metrics can tell
you what the user does but it will never
tell you why so take an example we can
clearly see that we have a high
acquisition like many people come to our
page we have high activation they use
our product and we can clearly see from
metrics that they don't come back but we
don't know why that's where the
qualitative research comes in to
actually talking to people so after a
while we sort of grew out to the coffee
shop method and we started hitting more
complex problems and that's where you
set up sort of a proper user testing
session and for us it was very important
having include the entire team so that
you have different perspectives on how
you solve problems so we SAT together
diverse teams of designers a researcher
engineer and marketing and they together
worked with talking to users actually
being there in the feedback creating
these prototypes together and testing
out the solution when we thought you had
something that worked that really helped
us understand the complete picture of a
problem instead of just having the user
researcher go out get all the answers
and then come back we sort of this is
the way we have to solve it then you
lose the perspective of example the
designer or the engineer and we make
prototypes to show people sometimes they
were on paper sometimes they were in
code we did whatever made sense at the
time what took the least effort for us
to do so this is an example of the new
room layout for mobile we tested out
where we want to test out if people
understood icons with the result text if
they understood the interaction that we
want to go and if they understood long
press and that kind of stuff so that was
a combination of both paper prototypes
and
code implementation right so when you do
reduce your research it needs to sort of
be focused on a target you can't really
go out there and interview everyone and
I see a lot of other application and we
did at ourselves in the beginning we
wanted to make a service for everyone
like that makes sense right we wanted to
make a service big we wanted to have
lots of users so naturally everyone and
their dog has to use us but it doesn't
really work because people have
different expectations so let me show
you a quick example of that so what do
you think is the difference between
these two users so the girl on the left
she's 18 years old she goes to high
school in Norway and she's one of our
teen ambassadors that is people that
sort of talk about a product and then we
include them in in the product
development and teach them how to sort
of do that kind of stuff she mostly
talks to her friends during class and
after school about various things and
they have a different usage pattern that
what you might expect they mute their
audio because they're in a privacy
sensitive setting so they won't don't
want a teacher or their parents to hear
about what they talk with their friends
they use chat a lot more and then on the
right you have slang he's my boss use
the sperian a lot naturally but he has
meetings so audio is very important to
him and useless meetings 121 while the
teen years or SAS group of friends
talking together so they don't expect
the same thing from the service but who
do you prioritize who do you get the
most growth from who do you want to
create the product for as our next
lesson that we had we have to get a
target market because in the beginning
we didn't and then we ended up doing all
these different things when we try to
solve problems that have different
solutions for different people so we
ended up choosing teens they have the
new interaction we haven't seen before
so we were confident that we could
create something that they wanted to use
that's none no other services we're
doing at the time and they have viral
growth because they share them with the
friends who shared with the larger group
rafael
you share with a larger group of friends
so we chose to implement stuff like
stickers bolder colors a better chat
instead of meeting invites booking
meetings email invites or calendar
updates or stuff like call in cell phone
numbers or that kinda stuff but it's
important to remember that even though
you choose a target that does not mean
that your product will only fit those
people for example our business users
loved our new stickers because when we
design this we solve problems for teens
but we made sure that we don't alienate
other people as well because the
problems that resolving are often
fundamentally the same thing but a
target lets us easily prioritize we can
easily say that no we're building this
feature for teens and we're not building
this because that was not priority right
now right then comes another problem
because once we started doing all of
this and we started getting it right
most of the time we started innovating
way too much what honestly because we
were overconfident because we had so
much success we thought that we could
change everything at once there were a
lot of things that we hated with current
apps or things that we thought we
couldn't do or things we want to change
so for example we knew that we need some
kind of user model but our entire
tagline for the server is no login so
naturally we couldn't have anything with
login or how do you create a user model
without logins we figure out I thought a
lot about it and figured out that yes
access profile that's lot better login
than anything else we made sure that the
forum was nowhere near recognizable as a
login form either and through user
testing this tested fine I mean we were
just not asking the right questions
because we were showing this in
isolation and most users are inclined to
say yes when asked you get this of
course they want to say yes if
do you get this or can you make this
work we're gonna click to do you
understand what send code means they do
but the expectation that I have what I
want to create the user is not access
profile or claim room so quick question
here where do you sign up I'm looking
against you answer but the up in the top
right corner the claim room button
that's basically where we wanted to
click because all the other cool
features that we built we're hidden
behind that little claim room button
there's got no way of telling you that
was sort of the main action that we
wanted you to do and you sure didn't
even see the like there was no sign up
button the sort of gets people going
usually so a lot of people did not end
up seeing the new stiff stuff that we
built which means that all the retention
mechanisms that we put in place where
for ninety percent of users that were
seen so I brings us to our next lesson
keep innovations to a minimum I firmly
believe that you have innovation points
that you get to spend for each product
that you have and once you've done
spending them then you have to do stuff
by the book like because users need to
feel familiar they need something to
compare this new experience that you're
giving them this new either way of doing
things to like and stuff it's something
that they have experienced before
otherwise they're going to feel confused
or you're going to make them feel stupid
because nobody wants to not get it
especially if your friends are saying oh
man this new service is so cool and then
they start using it and they don't get
anything and leaving your users feeling
stupid will ultimately make them leave
which is not what you want so eventually
we listened and we made logging and sign
up the way it was supposed to be and we
made it a better call to action and we
went from having two to three support
cases every day of people asking us
where do you log in like they've managed
to claim room but then they've sort of
switch computers or come to a new device
and I didn't figure out how to login
actually because it never said login
anywhere in our system we made sure of
that yeah here's someone laughing
this is a serious thing with it and
after we changed it we had we haven't
had a single support case about it in
eight months and perhaps longer now even
right it brings us to another lesson
that is listen for feedback because on a
real glad sort of the mild side the
empathy talk because a lot of the
feedback stuff is about having empathy
for users understanding and setting
yourself in their place and understand
the problems that they have with what
you're trying to create so you did a lot
of different things to listen feedback
the obvious choices are of course having
a support email or anything like that
but we also had set up something we call
the ambassador program which were teens
that liked our product we used to go out
and have lectures in schools about
coding or whatever and then teens that
were interested in sort of learning more
or talking to us we made them or abasa
ders so then we could use them to sort
of ask hey this new thing that we're
making does this make sense to you at
all or for the stickers like what
sticker should be great to that kind of
stuff that's also a good way to get and
listen for feedback is actually finding
our to users are and then reaching out
to them and asking hey do you actually
like our product or how can we make
stuff better for you but even if you do
everything right we think you do
everything right the coded right may
still break it all and this is a horror
story from from a time that we we had a
successful feature it did what if all
was supposed to do but something went
horribly horribly wrong so we introduced
a concept we called following which is
basically if you get notified when
someone sends a chat message or joins
the room or something that the intention
here was that the user wanted to figure
out or actually teens wanted to talk to
her friends and I wanted to know when
their friends were on the service and
what they were talking about they had a
fear of missing out the same was true
for teams they want to see if their team
was
in a stand-up or at a view and we tested
this well in beforehand we felt that we
really understood the problem I me of
course wanted people come back some
notifications a sort of a very obvious
way of doing that in a future itself
that was a success a lot of people
actually started coming back and they
used to future do IV we envisioned it
and the metrics looked good but then we
started seeing something weird the
performance of my server was was
horrible requests were taking more than
five seconds and this at first wasn't
very surprising to us because first we
had a sudden influx of many users the
teens that starting sparing it to their
friends and we saw a doubling of user
numbers and at the time we were running
a single server in Ireland with one no
J's process we did that for two years
and it worked fine but we figured like
some put scaling is going to be an issue
so we started working on improving that
of course but at the same time we saw
that there were two rooms with very
easily guessable room names that were
extremely active that every day of the
eye of the hour every hour of the day
and people were in there filling up the
with eight people I didn't think much
about it but one of the rooms were
actually owned by one of the team so we
went in there to check out what was
going on what we found was people just
chatting together getting to know each
other nothing serious but one one person
left another person joined this was sort
of sort of fine we thought we didn't
think much more of it but the
performance of the server got worse and
worse when we started shutting off more
and more features to try and actually
get it up and running how the core
service at least work and once we killed
notifications everything suddenly
improved so we sort of had like a hint
that where the problem was we started
investigating so it turns out that the
feature that we built had some duty
mostly technical debt and other yeah
reasons that come from having a product
running for two years some weird code
bats
and we had to sign this feature to be
mostly for six to seven people and we
haven't given much thought to
performance like at all it didn't really
matter if we did one or two extra
database queries we didn't look into
that but it turns out that for every
follower we were fetching the user data
from the database using this is actually
almost correctly copied from our from a
load base we're a map over each follower
and then we have something called the
user in richer which unless you were
familiar with the code and the pearson
implementing this worse not it actually
made a database query and this was fine
for ten maybe fifteen people but when we
had 500 plus people following a room for
every chat message you would do 500 and
then for some weird reason we were
throwing away the data which we got here
and then doing the same query three or
four more times which ended up resulting
we had two thousand database reads and a
thousand database rights / chat message
sent in those rooms directed all the
time which is crazy yeah so actually the
database was backed up that calls long
event cuse a node and triggered garbage
collection everything went to yeah
everything went amok really sonai should
be fixed it by having smarter queries
and we do both developers do we sort of
fix our problems but it's a nice example
of how the feature that you taught you
you knew exactly how it's going to be
used was used in a totally different way
than you expected with you and the code
that you write was actually negatively
impacting the performance of the servers
because of it and this happened because
when teens couldn't talk to their
friends when they weren't there they
were seeking other people to talk to you
and when they found these rooms with a
lot of users naturally they wanted to
follow those rooms that I could have
people to talk to you and it wasn't
generally like a good atmosphere in
these rooms as well there wasn't
anything like dangerous going on or
awkward going on really anyway I was a
bit of a regression but I hope to have
showed you that sort of to my own
experience that user experience is about
a lot more than just green and red
buttons it's about how you go about
understanding
how you talk to users how you find
minimal solutions to implement something
as fast as you can to test it out but
how you implement them it's about the
presentation and the messages you send
to users in the end and finally how you
refined that solution based on the
feedback and really it is about how you
write code how you approach problems and
how we communicate with your team and
your users so I really think that user
experience is everything allows it for
my talk more or less